my reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell the way
you're gonna be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in
let's get started so today
I am going to be reacting to the full
clip and I did cover this in Pearl daily
today but I just thought it was so
interesting I wanted to see the full
thing the full clip of Andrew Tate
meeting land of the plug and atom22 on
Aiden Ross's stream but guys before we
start make sure you put a one in the
chat if you think that it will have no
effect on their marriage put a two in
the chat if this will be devastating uh
let's pull up the footage King
I'm gonna I'm gonna try to put the chat
on my phone guys so I can see you
all right let's play it
can I hear it
okay let me start at the beginning
I can't hear it his wife to a live dude
could you turn it down I can't
stream they invited Adam Twitty two and
his wife to a live debate and this was
genuinely super interesting and you'll
see exactly why hey guys leave a like on
the video and subscribe with
notifications so you don't miss the
latest updates maybe just take a look at
this this was insane hi guys do you hear
me yeah I can hear you all hello this is
my friend um I don't know if you've
heard of him before his name is um
Andrew Tate never heard of him
hi nice to meet you nice to meet you how
are you
I'm pretty good that's good yeah good
Glenn I could see you know you have a
black microphone in your face it's very
nice does it remind you of anything uh
Andrew we have to be very careful with
this conversation and I'm gonna explain
why
we'll start by setting some ground rules
because it's very nice to meet these two
people and I've never met them in real
life and I believe in being respectful
to everybody that's who I am as a person
I believe in treating everybody with
respect and even if we're going to have
an interesting conversation and we're
going to have disagreements in this
debate perhaps that might evolve I'm not
going to sit here and insult anybody
that's not who I am so I know what
you're trying to make me do it and
you're trying to make me say something
which could be deemed defensive and
that's not what I'm going to do okay
we're all individuals and we can all
make our own choices we have a lot more
in common than we have uh separating us
because believe it or not the Matrix has
been out to get me too so that's it tell
me how bro they've been trying to cancel
me for years all kinds of made up sexual
assault [__] and everything under
the sun the same exact Playbook that
they've been using to try to take you
out to the games so you may disagree
with uh some of our sexual proclivities
but believe me me and Andrew tell you
we're victims of the same struggle
and I think once you get to a certain
level of Fame and influence every single
man is going to be hit with this I mean
the reason Aiden hasn't been hit by it
is because it's just so unbelievable
everyone knows I literally have though
bro I got kids like 30 times bro
for hanging around with chicks they said
you like had sex with a girl or whatever
you got sexual assaulting nothing like
that thank God yeah because everyone
knows they're not getting laid so that's
fine but
[Laughter]
all right you're telling me a rate 20
something year old can't find a woman to
sleep with
all right whatever bro whatever bro it
can't be true
what
oh you're gonna do a different stream
oh okay
this didn't demonetized it did it
okay
tip type and what
oh Aiden Ross
okay
your woman was in the Army okay
there we go all right guys sorry we're
starting over
since you know that you're you're
echoing way not even out of weight
what the [__]
Andrew I promise I'd even add them any
um
hello hey Lana
hi guys do you hear me
yes yeah I can hear you all hello Lemma
this Adam we can't hear you Lana this is
my friend um I don't know if you heard
of him before his name is um Andrew Tate
never heard of him
hi nice to meet you nice to meet you how
are you
I'm pretty good that's good yeah good
when I could see you know you have a
black microphone in your face it's very
nice
does it remind you of anything
uh Andrew
we have to be very careful with this
conversation and I'm going to explain
why
let's start by setting some ground rules
because it's very nice to meet these two
people and I've never met them in real
life and I believe in being respectful
to everybody that's who I am as a person
I believe in treating everybody with
respect and even if we're going to have
an interesting conversation
disagreements in this debate perhaps
that might evolve I'm not going to sit
here and insult anybody that's not who I
am so I know what you're trying to make
me do it and you're trying to make me
say something which could be deemed
defensive and that's not what I'm gonna
do I'm not sure we're all individuals
and we can all make our own choices you
have a lot more in common than we have
uh separating us because believe it or
not the Matrix has been out to get me
too so that's it tell me how sure
they've been trying to cancel me for
years all kinds of made up sexual
assault [__] and they're trying to
call him a racist too they're trying to
throw
it's like that's what they'll do they'll
throw sexism racism they'll throw
um Xena what's the Xena or homophobia
and they'll also throw
um Zionism it's all the isms
yeah everything under the sun the same
exact Playbook that they've been using
to try to take you out the game so you
may disagree with uh some of our sexual
proclivities but believe me me and
Andrew Tate we're victims of the same
struggle shout out of the Tupac
and I think once you get to a certain
level of Fame and influence every single
man is going to be hit with this I mean
the reason Aiden hasn't been hit by us
because it's just so unbelievable
I literally have though bro I got
canceled like 30 times bro
for hanging around with chicks they said
you like had sex with a girl or whatever
you got sexual stuff something like that
thank God exactly what I mean yeah
because everyone knows you're not
getting laid so that's fine but when
you're in actually High State it's
mayors
whatever bro whatever bro wait Adam
agreed with it and something came true
say again sorry I know trans girls I
know girls who have [__] Aiden so I
don't think that's totally true what how
do you know this
I know all about you Aiden
tell me all about Aiden bro hey what is
this
I know like 10 trans chicks that Aiden
[__] all right see now people are
gonna believe that [__] it's not true at
all come on bro you know it's not true
Andrew I swear to God I've never [__]
the trans girl before all my life let me
tell you all a story
when I was about 25 I was living in
Thailand
and I must be the only man who lived in
Thailand for because I was fighting so I
lived there for two years and I lived
there and I must be the only man who
lived in Thailand I've never paid for
sex never slept with a prostitute none
of none of the weird [__] so I'm living
in Thailand and I had this Russian
girlfriend and then she went back to
Russia and I was a bit lonely and I
thought okay I'm gonna try and get
myself a new girlfriend and by
coincidence the same day I met this
beautiful Swedish girl and she was
backpacking and I met her I went up to
her and started saying hello blah blah
blah we agreed to go for a drink that
night after talking to her I was walking
home and as I was walking this
transsexual who must have been about 55
56 had a couple teeth missing some man
clearly a man I don't want to you know
misgender clearly a man what was a
transsexual was walking across the road
from me and he slash she pointed at me
and said hey
I can tell by how you walk you have a
big dick what the [__] and I looked back
at this transsexual and thought well
I'll take the compliment and I said yes
that's true thank you very much and I
continued on my walk that was the end of
the story until nine o'clock rolls
around I get on my motorcycle I go down
to this bar to meet this Swedish girl
I'm sitting there I get drinks on the
table she turns up 20 minutes late and
I'm sitting there with a Swedish girl
and after an hour and a half of drinking
and enjoying each other's company I'd
already kissed her twice I was due to go
back to her house because my house was a
dump but she had more money than me and
we're gonna go and stay at hers when the
transsexual walks in the bar and in
front of the entire bar she walks in and
points to me across the bar and goes
that big dick
and the entire bar stops and looks at
her the old transsexual with missing
teeth and then looks at me and I tried
to explain for the following 10 minutes
of this Swedish girl that I have never
slept with this person I don't know why
she says I have a big dick and I've
never been with her and I don't know
what I just saw her on the street and
she didn't believe me she went toilet
and never returned that's a story from
when my lonely night in Thailand that's
true and it completely happened you
never give a [__] a shot
I've never given a [__] a shot no am
I missing out Adam I haven't done it
either but I went out to Thailand when I
was like uh 19 20 and the ladyboys are
out there and some of them even back
then this was like 20 years ago they
were doing a pretty impressive ruse like
they they looked like more of a woman
than a lot of women that I know so yeah
shout out to them
what if your boyfriend left you for a
trans person
would you I'm just thinking I would
never
that's like the epitome of insulting
like
you got left for a man like a man can be
a better girlfriend than you
that would be a low point that would be
low I'm a dude it was a really
interesting site
he was saying some [__] to her running
his mouth and she literally fought like
a man and beat the [__] out of him and
it was pretty interesting to see heels
on and everything all right can I just
address the elephant in the room why is
nobody talking yo Selena you just you
just finished I heard the videos going
crazy on PornHub you guys crashed it
um
it's all my only fans no oh sorry so
Adam if you don't I'm sorry uh Andrew
what happened was I don't know yeah I
don't know if you heard Andrew they did
a video
um basically Adam and them they're
married they're you know they've been
married for a while they have a
beautiful family
um and uh basically one day uh they
decided to uh basically Adam said uh hey
hun you can go ahead and get a BBC by
this guy so they had a big black uh [__]
insert her puss and uh
it's not in the video
and um that's true pretty much what
happened and uh I don't get it what
wasn't in the video
oh
uh thoughts Andrew
Well I think I mentioned this on one of
my previous podcasts I said that I
wouldn't personally do that bro but it's
not my personal preference but I want to
make something clear I I I'm really
careful about
what I say to people I don't want to
insult anybody that's not who I am as a
person if that's their personal decision
to make then they can make their own
personal decisions and do as they please
I'm not here to sit and say they
shouldn't do it all I can say is that I
wouldn't personally do that that's not
something I would allow my woman to do
but perhaps I'm missing something maybe
I can maybe you can tell me why I'm I'm
wrong I'm not sure would you guys let
your wife do that yeah the thing that
he's the most important piece of context
that is missing is the fact that we
already had been doing porn for I mean
maybe five six years or I'm not trying
to be rude
but does it like matter I don't think
the context matters like you think it
matters
I don't know maybe
I'm old-fashioned I just I
I don't think it matters I don't think
that's like the winning point that you
think it is since the very beginning of
our relationship and you know she is 32.
she is a mother realistically she's not
gonna be doing this forever but we
decided that it made a lot of sense for
her to you know seize upon the moment
the fact that she's still got her youth
about her and slurp up a black [__] for
the [__] paper man he likes it he
liked watching the video yeah I was kind
of turning on that I'm not gonna lie
sorry one more time Lena right correct
Lena Lena yes Lena do you think that you
have an emotional attachment to this man
now or like you literally wouldn't care
what happened to him let's say heaven
forbid something I don't know he he got
locked up and went to jail or something
like would you care or would you
literally you have zero interest in him
as an individual feel for him as I would
feel for like almost anyone I'd ever met
who went to jail but like no offense
Jason I see you as like a male sex doll
like no no emotional attachment to him
whatsoever
I have my emotional attachment okay well
then if you if you're if you're capable
of keeping that divide then I'm not here
to insult you and the reason I don't
understand
I'm kidding maybe it's just the life
I've lived
but I think the internet has [__] the
world up and I think one of the ways
it's messed the world up is everybody's
constantly running their mouths and the
world I'm from and the life I've lived
if you insult somebody it's it's
you have to be prepared to defend that
opinion and I know people who have run
their mouths and then have gotten
getting shot for it and I I don't like
to sit around and insult people unless I
have a genuine beef with them so I'm not
here to judge you or your life object
can just say that it's not something I
would personally do if you feel like
you're no emotional attachment to the
guy I think that's a good thing I think
your heart should be in one place Andrew
objectively you could definitely beat
the [__] out of me but one time I was
hanging out with the UFC fighter Donald
cowboy Cerrone and he pulled up some old
Andrew tape uh kickboxing matches and
was showing me them and did a pretty
good job of making the point of this guy
can't fight which I am not uh in a
position to judge but I have had that
experience where the former UFC champion
has basically told me about what a [__]
you are which I don't agree with I'm a
fan of the top G I like everything that
you're doing out here but I I think you
and Donald Cerrone need to settle this
in the in the Square
well that's the thing about fighting all
right the thing about fighting as a
sport is that everybody who watches it
goes this guy can't fight or everyone at
home who's never even fault says this
guy can't fight or other Fighters say
this guy can't fight which is why as a
fighter you constantly feel like you
have something to prove even if you win
100 fights in a row there's always going
to be someone out there since you can't
fight I'd like to think that my record
stands for itself I've had 88 fights
that's like all of these struggle
channels that are like
oh pearls views are low or whatever when
I'm like
one of the top thousand YouTube channels
in the US
like why don't you try to get like a
hundred views of video Diane it's like
all these guys that have never fought
are like oh Andrew take can't fight it's
like why don't you you start fighting
and see how that goes for you
but you know I guess call me crazy call
me
insane I don't know I had a bunch of
fights a four-time world champion I
fought a bunch of rules including MMA
and I did my very best and I wanted
bunch of titles and made some money and
beat a bunch of people and of course
there's always gonna be someone who
watches me and says I can fight there's
a bunch of videos that say I can and
that's the Oddity who says I can't but
I'm very happy with who I am in my
career and what I've achieved and I'm
very confident in my abilities so it is
what it is and as for Cerrone
I've heard of him didn't he get didn't
McGregor finish him pretty quick
sure but either way we need to settle
that score at some point I just want to
throw that out there but you know I
don't know if we do I don't know if I
need you know because and this is
something I want to make clear as well I
don't know if I need beef with people on
the internet I see a lot of this I see a
lot of people constantly beat each other
and all these arguments Etc I don't need
any of those things I'm fighting against
the judicial system I'm fighting against
the most powerful people in the world
trying to silence me I have enough
battles in my life I don't have time to
be [__] tweet beefing with some dude
if he has a problem with me you can come
to my house he knows where I am everyone
knows where I am until then I have no
problems with anybody so as for Cerrone
if he thinks I can't fight then if he
wants to tell me to my face and kick my
ass he's welcome to try and I strongly
believe you would regret that decision
and that's as far as I need to take it
right so your brother Tristan was in my
DMs like really sincerely trying to
convince me that I have made a very
grave error a massive mistake as a
result of how having let my wife shoot
with another man myself personally
having been you know a couple weeks
removed from the actual incident
happening
I don't really how much did you make
I need to know what was worth this I
feel like I made a mistake it feels like
some pretty regular boys you know I was
a little bit jealous at first it's kind
of a weird feeling knowing that your
your woman was in the arms of another
man Even if it was uh only for a few
hours but it's interesting you don't
seem like you have as much of a a real
like moral
issue with with the act itself oh well
I can give you my opinion on why I
wouldn't ever do it and I think the
reason I wouldn't ever do it is because
I believe that a man and a woman have a
connection between them and I think that
connection is solidified by sexual
exclusivity from the females part and I
believe there's an energy chord between
and I think that once that's broken with
another man I do believe there's a
degree of the connection which is
damaged and I think that when the
relationship is good perhaps you will
not feel it but when the relationship is
bad or when arguments start to happen or
you start to get on each other's nerves
you might notice a slight difference in
Behavior because I do also think that
once the seal has been broken I'll give
you an example the four minute mile was
impossible to achieve they believed
until one man ran the four minute mile
and then a bunch of people around the
four minute mile so once the seal has
been broken for example let's say your
wife's sleeping with another man the
idea I'll sleep with another man is not
as intimidating as it was once once was
and perhaps the idea of sitting through
an argument or sitting through a rough
patch in a relationship and continuing
to try to work it out as opposed to just
jumping on new man it might be less
appealing than it once was previously so
I believe personally if my woman had
already slept with another man she's
more likely to just give up in the
relationship and sleep with another man
again in a rough patch that's my
personal facts
say again why would I I mean I've never
cheated on you like even in the lowest
terms of cheating like responding to a
DM from somebody or anything like I've
never done any of that everything in our
relationship has been out in the open
um you know like all my messages with
the person that I worked with I was like
hey just so you know these are the
messages
um and like Adam has [__] about 200
women in front of me and he cheated on
me so like you know Adam Adam that's
terrible
hahaha
we all got our issues hey let me just
tell you about a half hour ago I was
laying on the floor in the adjacent
office with a large Italian ass shaking
on top of my face she does this thing
called Brazilian face sitting uh he
almost died it's gonna appear on
onlyplugtalk.com which is our weekly
podcast where we interview and then [__]
a different girl every single week and
this girl was really cutting off my
ability to breathe and when I would grab
her ass and try to move her ass off of
my face she would grab my hands and hold
on to them so that I wasn't able to
escape and Lena was was one boss she was
giving me head drawing all this and so I
don't know do you feel like that affects
our connection at all because I can
after having you shot with this guy I
can kind of understand why that [__]
doesn't matter to you because you and
the other guy it don't really matter to
me at this point I I think it's well my
personal view is that it's very
different from for a woman than it is
for a man and I think that and I hope
I'm wrong if your relationship reaches a
rough patch perhaps the idea of being
with another man will be more tempting
than once previously was because the
Seal's already been broken that's my
personal view I don't with all due
respect care what you want to do with
your own relationship if it makes you
happy it should make you happy and
that's fine and it's your decision to
make it's not my decision to make I'm
just telling that I wouldn't do it I can
give you admiration for a degree to how
well you've dealt with the
pressure I guess or the hate or the
backlash I mean you've handled it pretty
well which I guess is good not a lot of
people can do that so I have to give you
some degree of respect for that but um I
guess you expected all that before you
made the decision to do it right yeah I
did and I mean I've got I've caught a
lot of flack because when you first
commented on Me on the uh Tucker Carlson
show I left an Instagram comment that
said if he's the top G I want to be the
bottom G so I do want to extend an
invite that if you were ever interested
in doing your first ever double
penetration scene that me and Lena I
mean I don't want to speak for you but I
feel like Yo dude would he be a suitable
candidate can I tap them in I don't know
no
[Music]
can I film
am I supposed to be like impressed by
the
I'm sorry guys I just I don't even know
what to add to this right now
Tate is a way with words he dance he
that man is a politician let me tell you
that man is apology Andrew you know
you're out Aiden you're not in you're
not in this conversation anymore
fair enough go ahead Andrew would you
would you would you Andrew would you
double penetrate a bro would you would
you do that Andrew go ahead finish the
answer questions together is that chill
there's absolutely zero percent chance
of that happening
and it's not because Elena is
particularly unattractive it's because
she's married to Adam and I have no
interest in degenerate pointless sex and
I have no interest in making a spectacle
of myself or
even just involving myself in anything
which I deem to be
overall Haram and pointless that's just
not something I'd be interested in
there's not there's not a single amount
of money on the planet you could pay me
to to undertake so shout out to you he's
not doing double immigration because I I
respect you all so much
um I'm with Andrew by the way I couldn't
get paid any amount of money to [__] no
no offense Adam respect you degenerate
sex I'm not with that no matter you make
dollars a month sitting on your ass so
uh and that's from one sponsor I think
right so uh stop exposing it no I mean I
read it I read it online
um but yeah I'm with Andrew on that one
uh Andrew so do you two Think You're
Gonna Stay Together Forever
um I mean in life Adam she's on me again
maybe not
oh my gosh I'm gonna go back
but Rachel had a really good point
shout out Rachel Wilson hello Adam is
just going around offering his wife to
any man above him in hierarchy like a
true cook
it's actually really true everyone that
he's offered his wife to is like above
him in status and hierarchy
but yeah I'm with Andrew on that one uh
so do you two think you're going to stay
together forever
[Music]
um I mean unless Adam she's on me again
maybe not but I'm not a cheater anymore
I left that in the past
divorce don't you think people are gonna
attribute it to this event
like I always think that we're gonna be
together forever I mean we didn't get
married I like how they say think
it's like unless it's almost like she
has it in the back of his her mind that
he's gonna cheat
I know a girl like this where it's like
which I'm not I'm not even saying she's
doing this but where it's like they can
almost like look for cheating as a way
to get out because that's kind of their
exit plan anyway
I I hope it's not just got married but
uh it is unfortunate that if like in 10
years we break up because like let's say
he cheated on me everyone's gonna blame
it on the fact that I [__] Jason in
July of 2020. this is the interesting
morals how they'll have sex with other
women together but cheating like this is
why I say like why does cheating have to
be the end-all be-all
you know
it's a little bit hypocritical I think
as women it's like we'll come in
non-virgins she's literally having sex
with another dude and I know maybe he
co-signed it or whatever but like the
action is the same so it's really
interesting that
she thinks the cheating is so different
I don't think anyone's gonna think about
anything else nobody's gonna be thinking
about the fact that we did this in 10
years which when you're in the middle of
the storm and everybody's freaking out
on you every day it's kind of easy to
feel like oh this is going to Define my
life going forward now that may be true
to some extent because this has been
such a thing but I don't really think
that it's that likely to follow us 10
years into the future I don't know my
hopes is to my hope is to be with Adam
forever that is what I want and again
last thing I want to say is this
hope you see that my hope I hope to be
with him together it's like
it's really a choice you know what I
mean like marriage and love all that
[__] is a choice it's not it's not about
feelings and this is the problem women
it's based on we hope we think
I don't know have you ever talked to a
girl that's like head over heels in love
with a guy
I just I don't think that's the answer
they'd give but maybe maybe I'm just
psychoanalyzing I don't know what's this
but wait Selena which which sex was
better because you haven't had it Adam's
you an app sorry Jason was the first
Dick you've had right you know what let
me let me say something
I find this very uncomfortable to talk
about there's not many things I find
uncomfortable but I just find this
uncomfortable to talk about and the
reason is it's not because I mean I'm an
adult I know what sex is of course I've
lived a very varied life I just feel
like
I don't know we have so many people
watching us
and we're just talking about dick and
vagina do you think this is
below
us I don't know we're all pretty
intelligent people we talk about the
Matrix and how they're trying to dumb us
all down and trying to control all of
our minds and this base Instinct talk I
find it very
uncomfortable I don't find I'm not
comfortable being on this stream if I
was sitting with a woman next to me the
last thing I would talk about is our
personal life I just don't think it's
the smart thing to do and I don't think
that it is I don't have any interest in
the personal sex life of any married
couple and I don't want to hear about it
and I don't want to talk about it and I
just find it very uncomfortable I'm
extremely uncomfortable in this
situation that's the truth and I'm not
saying that from a position of weakness
I'm saying it from a position of
strength I don't like talking about
these things I don't like talking about
women getting [__] I don't like
talking about what I do with women I
don't like talking about any of it I
think that what I do in the bedroom with
a woman who I care about should be to a
degree sacred and I think it should be
completely private absolutely and I
don't want to hear about anyone else
[__] I like how Adam or Aiden just
switches up
he just kind of goes with whatever like
he's asking the question he's like yeah
it should be private also guys like the
video there's over 2 000 of you watching
um and we don't have a hundred likes
this is crazy this is oh we have 400 I
lied
um but we we should at least get to a
thousand likes if there's 2 000 of you
in here I'm gonna play the video
but if you guys don't like it if I don't
get to a thousand likes in the next five
minutes I'm gonna pause it I know
something clear to this I've never
watched I don't watch porn I've never
bought and only fans I've never paid for
sex my relationship with sex is involves
love and I don't think it should happen
outside of love and I think that's the
way that sex should operate and I think
that when you decide and once again I
could be wrong when you decide to keep
sex exclusively for love there's
something beautiful and special about it
and if you decide not to do that then
you keep chasing a new high and you can
have threesomes and [__] a bunch of
girls and I'm not saying I haven't done
it but eventually you're constantly just
chasing a new high and you end up just
doing something weird whereas if you
just say I always have sex with girls I
love then it's always special and it's
always pretty sacred and you get to just
enjoy it that way and beautiful children
are birthed and life goes on uh in maybe
like the last five years of our
relationship I can really only think of
maybe like one or two times that we've
had sex with a girl off camera for the
most part we are monogamous we just [__]
around on camera and I think if anything
our realization is is that the world is
so extremely fascinated by a couple like
us who are open-minded sexually because
there's a lot of conversations about
polyamorous relationships and you know
in our case I do think it's kind of
disingenuous for everybody to act like
we're in this crazy poly relationship
when we actually are monogamous uh
besides on camera but I mean for us it's
I'm sorry to to the rest of the world
that is not monogamous okay like to the
rest of the world we don't consider that
monogamy I barely even consider normal
marriage monogamy
um because it used to be one for a
lifetime now you're getting 200 chicks
another dude this is
to the average person I'm sorry Adam not
monogamy really like a porn thing you
know she shot this scene with this dude
as much as she may have enjoyed it or
not enjoyed it it was a money decision
it was like oh this is going to be a big
move for my career and for our family
we're going to be able to retire off of
this money so that that was the reason
for it not like oh I'm just dying to
have another dick in my mouth I
understand and I'm not a saint I'm not
saying sitting here trying to say I'm a
saint I'm not trying to talk from a
position of authority but I have perhaps
maybe it's my fight career which Cerrone
doesn't respect or maybe it's something
else but I think that you can achieve a
lot of happiness in life through
actually reducing your exposure to
certain things I'll give you an example
I'm not particularly a foodie but I will
only eat once a day sometimes I don't
eat for two or three days at a time and
that's the reason I love a steak so
right now I have unlimited sexual
options because I am the top G and I'm
the most famous man on the planet and
thousands of women a week are constantly
trying to throw themselves at me and the
reason I reject them all is because I
don't think I would enjoy sex as a whole
if I slept with all these women the
reason I enjoy sex is because I say no
to everybody and say no to everything
and by reducing my exposure to something
that's how I still find it interesting
and that's how I still enjoy it so I
know what you're saying I'm just talking
from my personal experience I've I try
very hard to not give in to any
Temptations and try to avoid them and
I'm not saying I'm a perfect person but
by doing that I find satisfaction in the
world so if I feel like [__] I quite
often don't [__] uh corollary to that is
that we were just on uh we were all over
Italy and Spain and France on our
honeymoon and we're eating in five-star
restaurants every single day the best
food that's out there and by the end of
it
I didn't give a [__] at all about what I
was and now that I'm back home and I'm
uh you know eating on a pretty strict
diet and exercising and everything like
that you could go get me a McDonald's
[__] Big Mac and I'm gonna be on
cloud nine because it's just so much
more potent than the stuff that I'm
eating on a day-to-day basis so I would
say that in the sense that there are a
lot of guys out there who think that the
the key to happiness is just sleeping
with as many women as possible from my
perspective I'm infinitely more happy
just being in a nice salt I'm not even
gonna lie
and this is just very I want to tell you
guys the first video I saw of Andrew
Tate
was him having a cheating party and
inviting all the girls he like slept
with or whatever maybe it was an antic I
don't know
but he did have a cheating party where
he would literally like cheat on his
girlfriends in front of each other and I
was like oh my God this is crazy
I was very triggered but it's just
interesting like
the the switch or like the how much he's
evolved over the past like year two
years because his content like I
remember him going on fresh and fit and
talking about how he like cheated on
this girl or like he was sleeping with
one girl and then wanted to go sleep
with another girl in the other hotel and
like told her it was like a drug thing
or implied I don't remember what it was
exactly but it's just interesting to see
like how much he evolves over time
I mean I like it it's like character
development also guys um I'm sorry
there's over 2K of you in here
we don't we don't have a thousand likes
yet
we need to get 2 000 likes we're at 838
I'll give you guys one more chance
otherwise I'm gonna have to pause the
video okay the relationship where I can
really trust my partner as opposed to
the way I was Andrew before I got into
this relationship with her I was in the
streets I saved you I was bad for
[__] like five six seven girls a week
New Girls oh it was disgusting doing
cocaine drinking to an absurd degree
popping Xanax snorting perks [__] drugs
[__] drugs man yeah I was drinking lean
like Aiden Ross and now you know I'm
much happier I'm sitting here like
that's crazy all right well I agree and
and I just want to say that before
before you guys leave I agree I just
want to say that I wish you absolutely
the best I wish the best for everybody
on the planet and I have nothing against
you and I'm glad that you were happy
with your decision I hope it works out
fantastically for you and I hope you
stay together forever and you raise your
children because that's a beautiful
thing and that's what the world needs
more of so I wish you the absolute best
I think a lot of people expected us to
argue and I don't feel that way about
about you or your decisions and you seem
like very nice people so I wish you the
absolute best Atlanta I hope you had fun
and I hope you enjoy your marriage
Nico and [__] Myron make a trip to
Romania I want to be right there on the
PJ hanging out and talking about why
girls suck no oh no oh I draw the line
there we have one more porno to film so
we have to go yeah all right hey guys
thank you so much for coming on uh
Andrew Jake's ready
all right Adam
Paul someone said they're not gonna like
the video where I'm not a simp
oh that's funny that's funny 997 guys
we're three likes Away really
and now you're gonna say it's simping to
like a video everybody asks to like a
video
why is what if I ask because I'm a chick
now it's simping I'm gonna ask for money
I asked for a like but if you do want to
send super chats I'll accept those too
thank you
yeah baby just walking away
[Music]
they hit the hit the red button
all right so
we're good I'm at jaken real quick uh
yeah I think a lot of people expected me
to give them a hard time I'm not going
to give them a hard time I think that
whatever they decide to do whether it's
worked out perfectly for them or not
life will give them the lessons they
need to learn whether they're positive
or negative and it's not the life to do
that it's not that's true yeah that is
true
Jake
Jake what up man
training hard oh [__] yeah dude don't
stop honestly this is my the best shape
I've I've been in I'm excited for this
fight 18 days away damn
when you're getting in there Aiden
actually you know uh soon okay
um he's got to fight his battle against
lean first bro what is going on with
this lean [__] yes bro I'm clean what
the [__] is going on here you know what
I'll say this right now Jake after you
um you beat Diaz I actually I want to
get it I want to I want to get in some
work with you you know we'll do I don't
know who Diaz is
it's really interesting to see how the
Paul or the Logan and Jake Paul have
evolved over time too
um I think they've done a really I like
what they've done with fighting I think
it's
really unique that like now we can have
influencers fight and it's kind of like
I don't want to say revive the sports I
literally know nothing about fighting
but it's definitely brought more
attention to it
uh what oh king king's making
making
um he's got a fight coming up he's
fighting China if you guys remember
China was on the show a couple months
ago
yeah Kings we're doing a fight should I
put a one in the chat if I should be a
fighter put a one in the chat if I
should be a fighter and comment who I
should fight
um give me like a feminist the Miami
training on the hot sun you know what
I'm saying on the beach it's not just no
Aiden it's not just about the training I
think every man should have a
professional fight at some point in his
life one because of the pressure you're
under and how scary it is because
there's a lot of pressure because you're
putting your ego on the line and
secondly because you have to dedicate
yourself to a training camp completely
and fully you can't just do one pad
session and put it on the [__]
internet and talk about being a fighter
you need to dedicate yourself and try
hard and set a date where you have a
fair competition against another man and
put on the line that's what you need to
do as a man so you learn about yourself
okay yeah don't you don't you have beef
with like a some other streamers and
stuff too like one guy named Hassan but
he's like seven foot tall and he wears
dresses so I'm not I'm not gonna fight
that guy you're Andrew you're oh there
you go
is that the guy the guy I think it is
yes it is oh my God you're mate yeah
um but nah man I would love to get in
the ring I swear I actually they want me
to fight Kim K do you think I could be
Destiny they're telling me I should box
Destiny who do you think would win put a
one in the chat if I someone said lizzo
put a one in the chat if I would win in
a fight against destiny you don't want
to fight Lizardo
oh you think I'd lose
she might she might
eat you I get eaten no she couldn't I
would just do a light jog she couldn't
keep up you know what I mean
Molina they want me to fight Molina it
really really would
um one day
I think if you had a reason to to stop
sipping lean it would help you like you
know I'm excited I'm gonna leave for a
while now about a month
but you were you were texting my friend
like three days ago asking for a lean
plug
okay Andrew he's lost what is lean
do you know what that is
lean
what's codeine
it's like um it's like a painkiller oh
oh he's it oh he's a pain killer drug
addict it's like for cough like it helps
like yeah so he is that like bad for you
is that drugs yeah it's like abusing
drugs okay
someone said Angela Knight I don't know
who that is
you're talking about Jasper okay yeah it
was not three days ago I texted him like
a couple months ago about Lee
I haven't done lean in over a month you
can drug I'll take a drug test on stream
tomorrow you want me to do it do it chat
chat we want to see this okay okay fine
I'll do it no no all right we won't talk
about it we won't talk about it I'm
gonna do it for real I'm gonna do it
all right got you
um yeah I got you so look no you won't I
will you talk [__] no [__] the ship you
guys are gang up on me Jake are you
gonna fight Andrew Andrew you're gonna
fight James would you guys ever fight
well I'll tell you something let's talk
about this because there was a time
where I called out Jake Paul there was
that time so let's talk about that it's
when Jake first called out Conor I think
this was like four or five years ago is
that correct a long a while ago and I
said Jake I'll fight you I remember
saying it to him at the time I wasn't
nearly as known as I am now and then
since then I've made it very clear also
to the world I said that Jake I believe
is the best YouTube boxer I believe you
can beat them all and I think he's
trading very hard and a fight against
Jake would be a real fight and I do
believe he's working hard in the gym and
he's more of a boxer than he is a
YouTuber what Jake the best YouTube well
anyways I'm not on YouTube so I guess I
guess you think that you could take Jake
Paul
wow Jake if you're watching this my
producer King
he said he there's no way that man is
the best training on the planet
and you think you could win
look I don't know much about I don't
know much about boxing but I'm just like
I I know you you do your training in
like the park or whatever but I'm like
thinking this guy's got world-class
trainers training him every day and you
think you can win are you as delusional
as the women when I was in high school
we used to have a couple of our friends
that used to travel every summer to the
UK and us and they'll come back after
the holidays with their full kids like
they'll buy the latest Boots the latest
jerseys everything they had the best
coaches because their parents had money
to afford all of that but bruh when we
get on the pitch
Talent is Talent man yeah but over a
certain under a certain age yeah but if
he's been doing this for years do I do I
look like the regular guy to you
[Laughter]
now
I don't think we're gonna we're gonna
fight especially because of my current
legal situation I can't even leave my
house however
I do think that in terms of YouTube
boxing I'm glad it's came I'm glad it's
a space now I like the idea of people
would be fighting each other and I do
also and I want to make this clear to
everyone and I've said it multiple times
I do think Jake is the best of all the
YouTube boxes I don't think that can be
denied well thank you no I appreciate
that I I think yeah my answer to it
would have would be like if you figured
out your legal situation I I think you
should get in there because it would be
massive maybe maybe not with me maybe
with whoever it is but my friends I want
to see you first everyone wants to see
it it would make a bunch of money and I
don't want to say but before I was
arrested in December there was a
conversation on going about me fighting
someone and I'm not going to say who it
is because it didn't happen and I asked
for a lot of money and they offered me
all the money I wanted and it was very
close to being signed and then I
obviously ended up in a presentation
certain things changed but um yeah I
know the whole world wants to see it the
whole world would love for me to get in
there and fight somebody I'm very aware
of that
oh my gosh they should do it like at
their I don't know if they could with
the legal stuff but I'm like they should
do it at their mansion and do a fight
we'll help you lie we'll we'll set up
we'll we'll we'll sponsor it'll be like
a jpt sponsor if we could ever figure it
out I'll be down to do MMA or boxing
either like the pfl would make it happen
so if if you ever figure out the
situation I think it would be huge wait
Jake no we should you know what we
should do Jake while you're next
training I know you're only 18 days away
from a fight but next time you're
training and you want some sparring fly
to Romania and we'll Spar and we'll film
it and we'll decide if we want to
release it or not afterwards
all right the chat is going crazy they
don't believe me and they're asking for
my Ig nah don't don't worry I'm training
don't put your idea out there I'm
training put your put your IG
put it they need to follow the fight
Journey put it out there King
no no
I don't know what your ID is you could
tell them
is King omashola k i n g o m a t s o l e
go and check me out man I'm going to
whoop Jake Paul's ass but I have no
problem we can have a sparring match
anytime
yeah but we can't release it for free
that's like it's like giving the people
what they want for nothing that's kind
of crazy yeah guys I would love to you
know I'll spar two for you with what you
guys [__] uh Jake let's just go to
Romania we'll go 50 50 on the jet go to
Radio Jake and uh well Spar we could do
a threesome Spar I'm with it
why do you make everything sound weird
dude I'm down to just spar with you guys
for fun guys being dudes
[Laughter]
anyway yeah
have you ever been outside you look pale
uh I actually been outside in a long
time but uh Jake I have you know that
I'm gonna be going outside a lot more
now
and and that's a jake made an important
point because when it comes to these
fights he made an important point about
the people want to see it and that's
very valuable
so it's not as easy as people think to
just fight there's a whole bunch of
promotion behind it and things must be
done Etc because if it was that easy
like I said Jake and I could Spar of
course but that video would be worth
millions of dollars so we can't just
throw it on Twitter for free because the
whole world wants to see it
I mean I
I'd be up for it but I understand Jake's
a professional fighter when you're a
prize fighter you want a prize right
I know we should I mean we could still
Spar like ah that would be fun anyways
and maybe we put like little Clips out
not the whole thing or give people a
little teaser or something I don't know
we'll we'll figure it out Jay you know
Ryan well I can't leave the house Jake
so you know where I am I'm not going
anywhere I'm here Jake um you know
they're they're asking I know they're
gonna ask um still anything updates on
fighting KSI are you you would you still
be down to fight him is that still a
thing that's gonna happen in the future
I've been down you know I've been down
I've been trying to make it happen for a
long time and I think everyone can see
that and he's the one that has always
had an excuse with music or touring
um and then he wants to drain the weight
down to 180 pounds which I agree to if
he wanted to do Winner Takes all for all
the money and so he says okay sure we'll
do Winner Takes all he says it on
Twitter and then we go behind the scenes
for the negotiations with his manager
and his manager Ducks the whole entire
thing they're like oh no not winner saw
like only of extra million dollars
um so then there's like a weight thing
going back and forth
and it just seems to me that he doesn't
want to get it done
are Logan and and KSI really close or is
it all just a weird like promotional
thing
I think it's it's they're like
acquaintances
okay but
it is like this weird thing but they
both kind of like joke about that like
obviously thank you for the Pearl simp
task tax
appreciate the super and Logan be like
yeah we're best friends like and kind of
say it say it jokingly
um but obviously they're business
partners and that that whole entire
thing so
hmm
yeah interesting I just thought I'd ask
and I have nothing against Logan either
I think a lot of people think I have a
problem with Logan I don't have problems
with anybody I live with a pure heart
I'm a happy man but I just thought
they'd be I was just curious about that
because when KSI is running his mouth to
you I'm like why is Logan not punching
him in the face what the [__]
yeah business I guess is business
um it is it is weird it puts me in a
weird spot because like I don't know the
drama behind this do you know the drama
so at KSI was talking [__] about Jake
and Logan was still his friend I don't
even know what happened
I don't know the exact story but did all
these guys are always clowning each
other but they wouldn't actually get in
the ring and fight each other um I want
to fight if you want to fight let's
fight man I I don't I don't like you
when guys make a lot of noise and then
when it's time to get down then you
start hearing excuses and I'm even
saying that because I think China China
might run from this fight oh you think
he's gonna run yes
why
what did he say so
say something
he's got a feeling I just think like
when when you're faced with someone like
me you you'll probably be scared didn't
it but like it's easy to talk until you
have to actually fight yeah like at
bowling
[Laughter]
King talked so much ish about bowling
sort of blessing everyone thought and I
who talked no [__] I won at Team bowling
yeah I gotta I gotta talk about my
talents I don't know how to feel all the
masculine dudes need to get together and
hold a masculinity conference charge
admission I I personally don't like it
because it's like here's this guy that
constantly is dragging me down
constantly jumping at every opportunity
to to pull me down and to to fame me and
to say anything bad about me and then my
brother is like acting like he's best
friends with them and that even when
people ask like oh you know they asked
Logan like oh who would you pick in the
fight and Logan's like oh I don't know
that would be tough for me like no it's
really not like wait wait wait so when
you ask who eventually says like well I
would have to pick Jake but he he plays
both sides definitely and it it does get
it does get annoying but it's like I
also respect his hustle as an
entrepreneur and as a businessman
because he you know created this
multi-billion dollar company now with
his enemy and I can't hate on that I
want my brother to accomplish his goals
and I want I'm happy for him and he's so
successful in doing amazing and to me
that's I'm just proud of him I'm proud
to be related to him I'm happy for him
but definitely it hurts me sometimes
seeing that [__] for sure
what age do you think you're retired
Jake what do you guys got ksr Jake in
the fight man I have no idea I want to
be world champion and and that really is
my goal and to prove to anyone that I
actually can do it and to go from a
Disney Channel kid who you know was not
in the gym at all to a world champion I
think
um would be a remarkable story and I
think it would inspire a lot of other
kids to chase their dreams no matter how
wild or crazy or so how about your
producer steps in front of the camera so
we can see if he is formidable
send super chats for a king camera
National that they are so that's my goal
and I think I could do it in the next
three four years so probably maybe
retire when I'm like 30. hey can I oh my
God he's not even 30.
wow it's so crazy how much life these
guys have lived like you know what I
mean I feel like they've been famous
forever
you ever wonder if being like famous at
a young age makes men more feminine
because there's money in drama which is
like typically more women
here I mean like because you wonder why
a lot of these guys I mean not him in
particular but like are a bit more like
feminine and I I like I think it's like
because social media kind of pays you to
be and so it's like if you're paying
dudes millions of dollars to get into
drama and all that stuff like you're
kind of gonna see it question real quick
when you guys are fighting uh like do
you guys did you guys develop like any
problems from it like brain damage or
anything like that like does it like
you're like do you guys develop any like
physical issues
well you can be unfortunate you can be
unlucky and that's the whole thing about
fighting that's why it's so universally
respected yeah and I even said I even
said this to KSI I said it when then he
replied something stupid because he's
low IQ and I said ultimately at the end
of the day anybody who interested the
ring to a degree I respect because
you're putting your ego on the line and
you're also putting your health on the
line it's pretty as close as you can get
to the Gladiator pit in Modern Times And
I know people who have entered the ring
and unfortunately they've exited and
they've never been the same and some of
them are my teammates and some of them
are my opponents and it's it's sad
always and it's yeah bad things can
happen in there it's it's real I've been
very fortunate and I wish there was a
world in which nobody ever picked up any
kind of damage from it but it's a real
possibility you have to keep in mind
every time you're training for a fight
so yeah it's scary
gotcha
I think lean is the worst for your brain
than boxing though facts man that's why
I kicked the cup had to Jake
how to kick it are you still Amy
oh my gosh sorry guys I was looking at
Twitter
this girl was like come on my show
or she was like a Booker for this other
show
she said her first tweet
you know why I can't stand Pearl I'm
like lady
why would you invite me like
weird it's like weird Behavior social
media makes people so weird this is
really crazy bro I can't bro like I'm
not gonna lie I can't get away from lean
why you know I'm not you know I'm not
Jake
I know you're not
it's been a while since we talked what
do you mean like a month ago well like a
heart to heart yeah true yeah
um no I'm not I'm not Jake no
no
no yeah well this YouTube boxing thing I
think is a fantastic opportunity for a
bunch of people who are constantly just
talking [__] to each other to actually
do something about it and I think if
people have a genuine issue with each
other then they should fight and sort it
out I don't think there's anything wrong
with that I think that's that's the best
thing about it and uh it's interesting
to hear what Jake's saying about KSI not
wanting to fight him because I think
that's the fight everybody would really
want to see I think that's gonna be the
biggest one
perhaps one of the biggest ones you can
make right now for sure for sure and
I've done everything I can
Rachel Wilson says I can't stand you
come on my show
people will do to me they'll be like I
hate this [__] and then they'll be in
my DMs will you collab with me I'm like
well
this is just a bit
I don't know but it's really weird the
visceral reaction I get from people
oldies old old it happened multiple
multiple times
um but at some point he has to step up
to the plate and I think at some point
it has to happen just for the culture
and I know he wants it it's just a
matter of timing and
All Things Considered uh let's see we'll
see whose corner Logan's in hopefully
he's in the right corner because you
know Brotherhood is the most important
thing and I I think you would I'd like
to believe he would choose you of course
when push came to shove
yeah no I I think deep down he wants me
to win a hundred percent but it just the
way he like presents that sometimes
um and that's what's weird about it for
me is he's the one who when he lost to
KSI he's like you have to go beat him
and that's really at first like what
motivated me a lot to get into the gym
and train so hard as I saw my brother
being broken and sad and and the loss
was really affecting him and he was like
he kind of like bestowed this thing on
me to like go get our family's name
um and so then that's why it's like
confusing for me the situation that
they're they're really in is Logan there
now
no no he I mean he's in Puerto Rico but
he's not at the house right now I was
gonna say hello
Nate Diaz is here
actually in Puerto Rico he's a he's like
in the other house over here have you
seen him training
um
if we go can we get him yeah yeah oh
[__]
who's Nate Diaz
do you know who that is
I think is a former UFC fighter ah okay
I can get him I can go oh my God
Andrew I'm a big fan of Diaz brothers
bro holy [__] I think like I'm gonna fan
out I think good good they deserve
respect they train very hard they're
Legends of the sport Andrew could you
introduce me to them please
I don't know them I've never spoke to
them before I want to introduce you
I'm gonna get nervous yourself all right
you're right right I got this [__] we
get nervous over a [__] stream look
at a computer screen
you're a nerd bro hey
dude
let's see if Nate's there
oh
is it what's that Focus
God damn it
off you said you were you said you were
nervous hey I'm a big fan bro I'm a big
fan
I I don't give a [__] [__] I heard you
like Jake Paul
Jake that's my brother
but who who you think's gonna win the
fight
I gotta go my brother Jake man I'm gonna
ride for my bro
[__] you man no but Mr Diaz
you lucky we weren't personal Stockton
slap the [__] off you [__] Mr Diaz I'm
a big fan you don't understand
I have a picture
no you're lucky I'm even on your [__]
ass stream damn bro
I'm a big fan bro I just want a picture
please [__] about you
bam
is that really how it would go down
Andrew
hey by the way thanks for having my back
[__] sorry about that dude I thought
interesting interesting life
yeah he's in a bad mood
ah man ah [__] you know what I kind of
for a second I kind of believe that and
because and I'll tell you why I'm I'm
from I'm a bit older right I'm 36 I
retired when I was 30 just like you said
and when I was fighting when I was 24 25
it was before social media so I turn up
to fights and I didn't even know who I
was fighting now it's all about who the
person is and promo Etc I turn up to a
fight in Russia or Moscow and I'd say to
my coach who am I fighting and obviously
all the Russian names are in Cyrillic
and we're like maybe him maybe him maybe
him we've done out to you get in the
ring and it's always the guy you it's
the biggest of them all of course the
one you hope it's not but uh there were
times where yeah I was training in the
same place as the guy was fighting or I
heard the guy was or me and the guy I
was fighting were warming up in the same
room
in in Slovenia so there's been times it
happened today of the fight days Hey
Jake what do you think is gonna happen
in the DS fight
man I think he's gonna be tough but
um I'm feeling so sharp right now I
brought in a new team new strength and
conditioning coaches new nutritionists
so this is the best I've ever felt
um and I'm getting better and better as
the rounds go on so I could see me
stopping him in like the sixth or
seventh round I just think he's not
gonna be able to keep up with my speed
and Power
just to address what you said about him
having the best coaches and I understand
all of that but you see the thing is you
can hire the best coaches are the
comments triggering you no little are
they no not at all well you can hire the
best coaches hire the best nutritionist
but you can't change the brain you have
and you think your brain's better bro my
brain is primed for fighting I'm a born
Warrior
[Laughter]
so you think if someone's like a skinny
dude he if he is the brain for it
of course if someone is skinny and he
has to bring for it he can definitely
train to become an incredible fighter
okay
okay so you're very confident I like
that are you gonna bet on it I am I'm
gonna put 100 000 on you
on God on God
I want to see a screenshot of that bet I
will I'm gonna post it yo when I put a
hundred thousand dollars on you Jake and
you secure my money you know I'll take
you out uh we'll go out take you out
take me on a date bro exactly
and Andrew can you know go with us
unfortunately due to unforeseen
circumstances I'm not allowed to leave
my house so I'm gonna miss it I'll just
stay here
I'm on month six of house arrest so far
and we'll see how long this continues
for so I'm gonna have to miss it
unfortunately
damn
so um that's [__] it's really been six
months do you do a lot of do you like
have the girls over do you like do a lot
of jerking off
are you talking to me
yeah yeah I I have the odd visitor Jake
and I don't jerk off because it's Haram
and God is always watching so that's not
something I partake in I'm allowed
visitors I just didn't know how it was
with house arrests like if you could
have visitors or not yeah I am allowed I
am alone you know you actually helped me
stop masturbating because every time
that I would masturbate I would think of
you and I'd be like nah this is not
right I'm gonna stop
Haram
and why is blessing calling me out in
the chat what's he saying in the chat
King has Kanye South bullying
does he have Kanye results I guess we'll
see
I guess
Pearl Davis versus any feminist yeah I
don't know why nobody's reached out to
me to fight somebody that would get so
many views that would do so well I'm an
athlete you know I'm tall what the [__]
I said I'ma stop doing this [__] now no
for real you put in my brain now I never
I haven't done it in months swear to God
I swear to God I haven't done that [__]
in months bro thank you for actually
stopping that porn addiction [__] porn
I don't know how men can be addicted to
porn I don't understand you must have
very few options in your life to find
yourself addicted to porn
actually I was thinking that I'm like
how are guys this Rich watching porn
like don't they just have like women
dming them 24 7 because they're rich
you know
they don't want to do with it
oh yeah we're the worst I forgot about
us
yeah they're like where we see these
essay accusations we're not dealing with
these chicks
Ezekiel okay
I mean every guy's jacked off in their
life before bro
but if you're I'm talking about a porn
addiction you make it sound like it's
something you can't help doing you must
have very few options if you end up
particular porn yeah true I'm really
really severely been addicted to lean
it's bad bro
hey James All right so Jake Jake I got
stabbed by a knife before do you want to
see it
I swear to God
what happened I was sleeping right and
my uh my uncle he was on meth and he
stabbed me in my sleep
or like just no reason or he was mad at
you or something uh he was on drugs he
thought I worked for the FBI
yeah it's funny what the hell Jake
no this is this [__] you say it's just
like I don't know if you're like special
or what but it's just crazy well it's
actually funny you say that Jake Andrew
I actually figured this out about myself
I'm definitely off in some way I believe
that I'm Autistic or like on the
spectrum of autism or something no no
I'm not even my joke and all [__] I
appreciate you not laughing Andrew and
Jake I don't know why you're laughing
I'm pretty sure I'm autistic
no they call everybody autistic stop it
stop that's the left throws around this
insult they'll be like oh you're
autistic everybody's autistic she's
autistic he's they just tell everyone
here's this outrageous individual
really
I'm kind of going I can't I can't do
this
[Laughter]
it's us again me and you hey Andrew
listen bro you know I love you right I
want some real [__] you're like my big
bro
thank you what
oh oh it's done someone said y'all
forgot Pearl's a volleyball athlete
she'll stretch she'll
slap a streamer out going night night
I've never heard back from my volleyball
Review Committee
on if I'm if I'm kicked out of England
volleyball or not I want to know
all right guys
um
let me know what you think in the
comments
um I thought this was interesting to see
Tate talk to Elena and Adam and just you
know get get his Real views it was a bit
more PC than I was hoping I'm a woman we
love the drama you know what I mean but
let me know what you guys think in the
comments like the video on your way out